[Music]
on this Monday night at an exclusive
television interview with the prime
minister justin trudeau on the shooting
down of a plane that killed so many
Canadians do you think that the people
who died on that plane are collateral
damage those Canadians would be right
now home with their families his promise
to the victims loved ones his message to
the u.s. and Iran plus the four big
questions Canadian investigators one
answered and the fury on the streets of
Iran as pressure builds on the regime
our Canadian donations spent after
haiti's earthquake in 2010 Global News
is following the money trail and
splitting airs the Queen breaks her
silence on Harry and Meghan's desire to
break away
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as Canadian investigators finally get
the visas they need to get into Iran the
prime minister says the regime there has
lots of questions left to answer in its
first television interview since the
Ukrainian Airlines flight was shot down
by an Iranian missile killing all 176
people on board including 57 Canadian
citizens Justin Trudeau told me there
isn't a lot of reason to trust Iran's
leaders in Iran lots of angry people
don't trust them either they defied
heavy security for a third day staging
protests many on board the plane were
from Iran and people are furious the
country's military killed its own people
and lied about it for days in Canada a
top CEO Michael McCain of Maple Leaf
Foods put out an extraordinary statement
on Twitter he says he's livid that US
government leaders unconstrained by
checks balances concocted an
ill-conceived plan to divert focus from
political woes and that at narcissist in
Washington tears world accomplishments
apart destabilizes region the anger is
real but Prime Minister Trudeau is being
more careful and diplomatic this is what
he told me
earlier today who do you blame when we
see rising tensions and conflict and
military actions anywhere in the world
it is always innocents who get
sideswiped by by conflict that's why in
my conversations with other world
leaders it no work that we're doing
together we're trying to de-escalate
this the tensions in the region you have
seen so much grief from the families
you've met many of them personally their
promising lives cut short so many
families across this country bereft now
is there any way that you can console
them
I think the grief they're going through
is not to be consoled right now they
want answers they express anger and
outrage but also just immeasurable pain
and what we can do what we have to do is
be there for them and answer the
questions they have that we have answers
for give them the support either here at
home or in Iran what questions are the
families asking what do they want it's a
range of things obviously in in my
conversations last week it was did Iran
do this and are they gonna take
responsibility and I think some of the
moves that that were made by the
international community including Canada
at sharing the evidence that we had even
at a preliminary stage encouraged Iran
to come forward and take responsibility
which is a good thing but the families
also have very tangible questions like
when can we bring our loved ones home to
Canada other remains how am I going to
pay my mortgage how am I gonna get the
supports I have because I can't go back
to work because I just lost my wife and
child and am completely lost but I still
have to pay the bills you know who's
gonna be held accountable for this we'll
be meeting on Thursday in London at
Canada House we're hosting those next
steps as we look to demanding justice I
think full admission acknowledgement of
responsibility and some form of
compensation is gonna have to come this
regime in Iran is not a one that has a
history of being accountable or
transparent and open so can Canadians
trust it do you think to deliver those
results I don't think there's a lot of
trust but I think the first indication
that they were willing to accept
responsibility and not try and cover it
up well
completely anyway you know it shows
there is a willingness to move forward
and take responsibility but that is
exactly the question I asked directly to
Prime Minister rouhani it forever had
president rouhani asking him to ensure
that there was justice for the victims
you've spoken to President rouhani once
I guess is that what was that
conversation like it was a conversation
which I was very firm about needing
answers for Canadians about the terrible
loss suffered by Canadians of Iranian
origin but also the entire Canadian
fabric that we've lost at university
professors that we've lost family
members we lost promising young people
and the community in the country is is
gutted did he make a pledge to you about
justice and accountability
the first pledges were around
cooperation on the investigation and a
full support to enable consular access
by Canadians and I can I can confirm
that all the visas that we requested to
get Canadians on the ground
investigators and folks for consular
support have been emitted by by Iran so
there are positive steps but there are
lots more to come and we're going to
make sure that they keep happening do
you know when families might get some
word on repatriation of the bodies which
will be so crucial to that is one of the
big questions that the families have
asked me for many of them it is a
religious priority to try and bury their
loved ones as quickly as possible
unfortunately in situations like this
we're talking about weeks perhaps even
months but consular officials are aware
of this and we're all working as quickly
as we possibly can to bring to bring
these people home we'll have more from
my interview with the prime minister a
little bit later coming up I asked him
who can mediate between the u.s. and
Iran and whether he thinks the innocent
people who died when that plane was hit
were collateral damage
Canada's Transportation Safety Board is
playing a special role in the
investigation TSP investigators will be
advising their Iranian counterparts who
under international law are leading the
inquiry our David akin is looking at
what specific questions the TSB will be
asking David that's right Donna two
investigators from Ken
transportation safety board that's the
TSB they spent the day flying from
Istanbul and Turkey to Iran's capital
Tehran and on Tuesday they will join the
investigation team the one led by Iran
their mission is to find out
not so much what happened but how and
why it happened so there's no doubt that
this aircraft was brought down by a
surface-to-air missile that I don't
think anybody doubts certainly all the
evidence suggests that the issue about
whether it was accidental or intentional
that is something that investigators
would normally pursue the TSB has four
priorities it wants the investigation to
focus on one establish the sequence of
events to identify the military
procedures that led to the firing of
that missile what were the sequence of
events what was the context that led
somebody to make such a tragic mistake
three get Iran's civilian aviation
authority to explain why it did not
close Iran's airspace when its military
began attacking us targets in Iraq that
night and four why were other airlines
flying off the same runway both before
and after flight 752 was hit by a
missile getting those answers will take
time this is not going to be a short
investigation regardless of who leads it
and David we know Iran is leading it the
prime minister told me today he doesn't
think there's a lot of reason to trust
the Iranian regime what is the TSB
saying
well Cathy Fox she's the TSB chair there
see she said she is quote cautiously
optimistic already we're seeing a
willingness and an openness on the part
of the Iranian a AIB to bring us closer
in its you know to give us more access
than we would normally have have that
could even amount to trusting Canada
with the extraction and analysis of the
black box data but there is also a
recognition that Iranian investigators
could produce a report that could dam
the Iranian government clearly some of
these questions are going to be very
uncomfortable for the country now the
TSB believes that an investigation that
is focused on safety and not focused on
assigning blame that's the best way to
prevent such disasters from ever
happening again Donna okay david aiken
in ottawa thank you experts from ukraine
are also on the ground and around but
iranian investigators are still in
possession of the Boeing 737 black boxes
and they're calling the shots on where
those devices will be examined our
Europe bureau chief crystal go man Singh
is in keeve tonight she spoke with
Ukraine's security and defense secretary
about the investigation
crystal Donna a number of the experts
deployed to the crash site in Tehran are
on their way back to keep we're told
that much of the initial investigation
has now wrapped up in the meantime a
senior Iranian official will be here
tomorrow
a detailed eye is needed to inspect the
mangled bits of metal for several days
now Ukrainian experts have been sorting
tagging and processing what's left of
the Boeing 737 and there are still many
questions about the black boxes I can
tell you that the recorders are still in
Iran I can tell you that they are
damaged but I can't give you a complete
assessment of the extent of the damage
because we haven't physically seen them
we've only seen photos in the battalion
Spadina children's clinic the Secretary
of National Security and Defense Council
for Ukraine told Global News were
waiting for a representative from Iran
to arrive and keeve tomorrow then a
decision will be made where the black
boxes will be decoded now Ukraine is
insisting it be done in this country but
Iran gets to make the call there is an
ongoing effort to ensure cooperation
between all affected countries this week
foreign affairs ministers will gather in
London to come up with the next steps
that includes compensation plans and a
united front is needed Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau says he wants justice and
accountability for victims
although exactly what that means has not
been identified
Ukraine has already organized an initial
payment to help those affected Alexi
danielaube acknowledges the pain of
Canadians ganado nullifies the Canadian
side is asking us for assistance when it
comes to the logistics of transporting
the remains he says Ukraine is helping
to repatriate the bodies for 17 families
the repatriation could happen relatively
quickly Ukrainian officials say the
Iranians are respectful on that front as
for the officials who are returning from
the crash site we hope to hear from them
tomorrow Donna all right crystal
commencing in Ukraine tonight thanks
it's not just Canadians who want answers
many people from Iran died on that plane
- and there's fury the military killed
its own people dissent in Iran those
standing up to the clerics and the
political leaders is risky past
demonstrations have ended in brutal
crackdowns Eric Sorenson looks at
whether this time could be a turning
point the massive protests represent a
remarkable turn for Tehran from bad to
worse Iran lost its top General in a US
air strike fired missiles that did
little harm to the Americans then shot
down a passenger plane with Iranian and
foreign civilians and evidence of an
initial cover-up has set off an
unprecedented backlash the latest an
Iranian news anchor resigned saying
online
I apologize for lying to you on TV for
13 years
it follows another blow to Iran's
controlled messaging the country's only
female Olympic medalist has defected
posting that she's been a propaganda
tool and I don't want to be part of
hypocrisy lies injustice and flattery
our children were killed in the sky she
says it's years of pent-up anger
unleashed the country's president
rouhani and even more shocking the
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini are at
risk of being ousted says this analysts
anymore we want that Iranian so this is
a very clear call for regime change u.s.
president Donald Trump has tweeted in
Farsi don't kill the protesters the
Iranian government spokesperson says
Trump is shedding croc
dial tears for our people he was
responsible for killing the most beloved
general Qasem Soleimani but just days
after the public outpouring for
Soleimani images of him have now been
torn down and Iran's government may be
at greater risk now than at any time
since the Revolution 40 years ago has
never been in this fragile situation
that it feels that there are wildcards
militias outside the country who were
armed by Soleimani in Lebanon Hezbollah
leader Hassan Nasrallah says it's time
for Iran's allies to retaliate but the
US has made it clear that Iran will pay
the price for any proxy attacks in the
Middle East and at the moment Iran's
beleaguered leadership appears to have
no appetite for a wider war Erik
Sorensen Global News Toronto it's the
1.4 billion dollar question how is the
money Canadians donated to Haitian
earthquake relief spent that's coming up
yesterday mark 10 years since Haiti was
devastated by a powerful earthquake
thousands of people died and Canadians
made a huge contribution to help Haiti
recover donating 1.4 billion dollars in
fact Haiti is the largest recipient of
Canadian aid in the Americas Antonia
Robart went back to find out how it's
been spent at this vocational school in
the hill sign of Carrefour just outside
port-au-prince the love for Canada is
strong the young people are benefiting
from the school the director says and
support from Canadians this school which
bears his name was built in memory of
RCMP sergeant mark Gallagher Gallagher
who was in Haiti ten years ago when a UN
mission training police officers was
killed in the earthquake they told us
that he was a what a great man the
school teaches the trades cooking
masonry and secretarial work among
others giving these young adults hope in
a country where hope is in short supply
if you darlin you won't be able to have
a good life in AD because you have to
learn you have to fight for what you
want a group in Canada called the
Friends of Mark Gallagher raised more
than a million dollars to help build
this school which opened in 2014 the
federal government gave another eight
hundred thousand dollars that's just
part of the overall aid money Canada has
given over the past ten years
immediately after the earthquake
Canadians opened their hearts and
wallets giving more than four hundred
and forty million dollars Canadian have
been very generously around the world
more than thirteen billion dollars was
earmarked for earthquake relief many
projects receive money including those
that provided shelter food and
healthcare but much of it some estimate
nearly half never made it to those who
need it most
mismanagement cost overruns even
allegations of corruption plagued the
aid effort big aid agencies sometimes
they have a problem of coordination and
this is where the bureaucracy probably
need to to be improved many lessons have
emerged from this devastation sadly far
too late for the millions of Haitians
desperate for help while at the school
that honors sergeant Gallagher the
success of that lesson is seen every day
Anthony Robart Global News car for Haley
I had the second part of our exclusive
interview with the Prime Minister that
2020 has just begun and already events
have taken place that no one could have
predicted the death of so many innocent
Canadians and others on board that
Ukrainian Airlines flight is a big test
for world leaders what happens next
between Iran and the US could shape not
just the next year but the next decade
here's more of my interview with Prime
Minister Trudeau do you think that the
people who died on that plane are
collateral damage in the tensions
between Iran and the US I think
there were no tensions if there was no
escalation recently in the region those
Canadians would be right now home with
their families this is something that
happens when you have conflict and war
innocents bear the brunt of it and it is
a reminder why all of us need to work so
hard on de-escalation on moving forward
to reduce tensions and find a pathway
that doesn't involve further conflict
and killing did the u.s. warn Canada
that it was going to target and kill
general Soleimani and potentially put
Canadian troops in dangers from the home
we didn't get a heads-up does that annoy
you is that the wrong thing to do the
u.s. makes its determinations we attempt
to work as an international community on
big issues but sometimes countries you
know take actions without informing
their allies would you have preferred to
have a warning obviously we don't have
time to air the full injury but it is
available on our website global news dot
CA / global national next Royal
compromises at the so-called Sandringham
summit this wasn't a great day for Queen
Elizabeth she finds herself mediating
another family drama this time involving
her grandson Harry and his wife Megan
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have
announced they don't want to be senior
Royals anymore and after a meeting with
her son and grandsons today the Queen
said in a statement she respects their
decision the couple will spend part of
the year in Canada at least as they
transition away from being full-time
Royals and that raises lots of questions
including who will pay the cost of their
security a report in the British press
says Prime Minister Trudeau has already
told the Queen Canada will pick up part
of the tab while they're here so I asked
him about that today I think most
Canadians are very supportive of of
having having Royals be here but how
that looks and what kind of costs has
involved this - lots of discussions yeah
The New York Times said I think that
we're giddy with excitement to have the
Duke and Duchess he also called us a
frigid wasteland so I
they did Vancouver today notwithstanding
I think when one has to take everything
written about Royals in the newspapers
with a very large pinch of salt well you
can say that again the Queen says Harry
and Megan made it clear that they don't
want to rely on public funds they want
to be financially independent that could
create a whole new template for how the
royal family functions Redman Shannon
explains a queen negotiating with her
own grandson Prince Harry after the Duke
of Sussex threw a wrench into the
workings of the royal family last week
he and the Duchess Megan want to step
back from their roles as senior Royals
and become financially independent a
shock but no surprise Harry has always
been wary of a British media that
hounded his mother and megan has been
the focus of some absurd stories from
the ruthless tabloids would it be fair
to say no really okay it's really been a
struggle yes even on Monday the Duke and
his brother refuted a news story
alleging William had bullied Harry out
of the family this meeting may do more
than just shape Harry and Megan's future
it could carve out a template for how
this institution operates for years to
come princes William and Charles were
involved in the summit too and
afterwards the Queen issued a statement
saying we respect and understand their
wish to live a more independent life as
a family while remaining a valued part
of my family it has therefore been
agreed that there will be a period of
transition in which the Sussex ah's will
spend time in canada and the UK but the
Queen said more details have yet to be
finalized certainly British taxpayers
will probably not want to foot the bill
for security if they think they're going
to be spending months and months either
in America or Canada
the RCMP is generally on the hook when
Royals are in canada royal expert Phil
Dampier says details on tax and income
will also be important it's gonna be
very difficult to be half in and half
out of the royal family some tricky
decisions remain for a family of
tradition yet again colliding with
modern realities Redman Shannon Global
News London
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is nack ouack New Brunswick we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global national calm
thanks for watching I hope to see you
here again tomorrow
bye bye
[Music]